ich bin ich aber käme ich mich das ist
die frage die wir uns im heutigen video
stellen meine lieben freunde denn ich
mache mal wieder ein quiz über mich
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal
lassen da los geht
wir fangen ja gar mit der ersten frage
und zwar wie heißt konkret dass
schwester bibiana okay da bin ich schon
baby jule daggi sarah oder katja dass
keiner treffen haben ist richtig also
meine schwester sarah aber ohne habe ich
glaube dennoch dass die das hier mein
was hat luca in dubai gesehen die
freiheit startet der burj khalifa das
anders diese mauer taj mahal oder katja
krawitz ich habe das burj khalifa
gesehen aber das ist halt auch hier
wieder komplett falsch geschrieben aber
gut die nächste frage wie heißt ein
zweiter kanal luca kran crafter konkret
was mache ich hier finde scheiß klug
oder cron crafter also das ist die erste
frage wo man nicht so richtig eine
antwort geben kann uns was ist luke
schuhe
die nächste frage wie heißt konto auf
das böse und das völlig legal highs balu
die nächste frage was ist konkret
scheint
also ich bin entweder scheiße schlaf
blöd um oder witzig definitiv scheiße
was hat von crafter als erster
sportleiter nachgebaute c4 katja kessler
oder verband ich habe ein video
hochgeladen wo ich vor teils sachen
nachgebaut haben und ich glaube es war
der ich habe erstens keine ahnung ich
würde mal sagen was hat er als letztes
item nachgebaut yanar ist einfach zwei
fragen bezüglich eines videos was ein
jahr her ist lama habe ich nun überhaupt
nicht nachgebaut chuck chuck könnte sein
verband mini ich glaube medi kids medi
kit hat aber auch wieder falsch
geschrieben
quiz hersteller ich würde dir das hier
empfehlen was hat sich konkret
tätowieren lassen julien beben luca
controller maxime ich habe mit lu crew
tätowieren lassen einem das ein stift
mit dem ich mir glauben henna tattoo mal
machen lassen auf wen hat konkreter
reagiert elmar wohl niemand hätte moritz
katja krause wird so da die wie ich habe
auch ich habe auch beide von denen schon
reagiert das ist eine reise ich würde
trotzdem was sagen katja letzte frage
ist wer ist contractors lieblings
youtube in domino kathi bibi daggi katja
oder lisa und lena m ich würde sagen
baby weil die er feiere ich echt mega
die auswertung des 7 allerdings habe ich
noch einen zweiten test vorbereitet er
uns vielleicht besser die antwort auf
die frage geben wird ob ich mich denn
überhaupt kenne
von ana ostric gegengewicht
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
luca hat sein account im jahre 2012
gegriffen da absolut keine ahnung er
lebt zurzeit in köln das ist auf jeden
fall war nächste frage lukas freundin
heißt julia das ist falsch
contra fda hat am 21 februar 1990 wurde
das auch falsch weil ich 96 geburtstag
habe lukas eigentlicher name ist lukas
und crafter liebt alpakas und ukulelen
das ist auch die wahrheit im nächste
frage luca shop kann man einen
schlüsselanhänger kaufen das ist auch
wahr
jackson kommen auch neue sachen jetzt um
15 uhr ist der youtuber größer als 1 75
jahre ich bin fünf meter dreißig lukas
lieblings youtube www youtube de ist das
ist komplett die wahrheit also die
freiheit wirklich übertrieben der test
war gut oder ja da war echt mega immer
auf die auswertung ich habe nur noch
etwa zehn anscheinend bist du ein sehr
treuer fan von lou kartentrick konnte
allerdings nur zum dritten und letzten
test nämlich heute vorbereitet habe um
zu schauen ob ich mich wirklich kenne
luca eröffnete seinen kanal am ersten
august 2010 ich glaube das erste war
bisher hat luca zwei bücher
herausgebracht stand februar 2009 10 das
ist auch wahr zu seiner gang gehört eine
ukulele einen hund aus nintendos und
eine wodkaflasche das ist auch wahr ist
einfach alles war rückers lieblingsfarbe
ist blau das ist falsch meine
lieblingsfarbe ist schwarz oder gelb
tatsächlich sein zweiter name lautet das
ist auch leider war luca war zweimal in
new york
ich war dreimal in new york also das ist
auch falsch luca liegt alpakas in der
tat sein markenzeichen ist ein dreieck
das ist komplett daneben luca hat eine
schwester oder einen bruder dass es auch
falsch habe nur eine schwester und luca
hatte hausverbot und 2 ich glaube das
ist falsch
fast sieben von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet wollt ihr mich verarschen
als wenn ich in keinem kurs alle fragen
über mich richtig beantworten konnte ich
mich so schlecht ja anders wenn ich das
heute wieder sein ist auch beendet meine
lieben freundes zu will dass das heutige
video bisschen kürzer geworden ist
allerdings bin ich gleich auch live
auftritts punkt iv strikt sich laser
luca um 18 uhr werde ich dort mit meiner
freunde mit jude zusammen fordert
spielen ich werde wieder auf youtube
videos reagieren ich werde fragen
beantworten zu ein paar dingen in
statement abgeben also um 18 uhr könnt
ihr gerne oft village.de laserdrucker
vorbeischauen wenn ich mich auf jeden
fall sehr freuen wenn wir uns noch
gleich im livestream wieder sehen würden
wenn euch das heutige dir gefallen hat
und das gerne einen daumen hoch da
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der dunkelheit und falls sie
abonnent seid dann klickt auf die glocke
dann bekommt die benachrichtigung sobald
ich ein neues video hochladen und leute
heute ist der 26 das heißt wenn du über
18 seid dann geht bitte wählen und wählt
einfach nicht die cdu danke
[Musik]